good
[Music]
hello how are you I greet you andrés gonzález
with the most outstanding headlines
for today Wednesday October 21
Governor Steve did only talk about a
possible increase in cases of Kobe 19 in
the fall however he did not talk about the
new restrictions but he emphasized  that
everyone follows the same old
rules like social distancing
wearing a mask and getting
tested if you feel sick he knows and he
mentioned that many Nevadans are
tired of the rules
several early voting locations
had long lines yesterday  For
example, the site located in Arroyo
Markets Fuertes near 215 and
Rainbow is reported to have been the
busiest in the southwest area of the valle
. The Clark County office in charg
of counting the ballots said that
10,000 people have already exercised their right
since Saturday,
on the other hand, health experts
advise getting the flu vaccine
this year due to the
coronavirus pandemic  us southern nevada health district is
hosting an event today at the
high school ok from
1:00 p.m. to 5:00 p.m. for
those who want to get a
flu shot no appointment is necessary the
other event will be held on the 4th of
november at silverado school
and now we have the weather forecast
we will be with
lower temperatures hovering around 80 degrees for the
whole week and with lows
above 50 it is already beginning to feel autumn
so prepare your coats that have a
nice day
I'm andrés gonzález and this was about
the news now in spanish
[Music]